she would have been in her late teens by
now but instead Molly Russell's life
ended when she was a child
today her family listened as the inquest
into her death examined whether the
policies of Instagram's parent company
meta contributed to her death
Elizabeth Lagoon who heads up health and
well-being policy at the company said
she was confident current policies
protect young people
she said I'm not aware of specific
research on the impact of content that
would be very difficult research to
undertake with ethical considerations
we are confident our policies do
consider the needs of our youngest users
some of the content Molly had liked or
saved on her Instagram account were
shown to the court they glamorize harm
to young people and were allegedly so
distressing to view that the lawyers
involved had discussed editing them
first the coroner gave those present at
the inquest the option to leave if they
were likely to be affected by the
material but he said Molly had no such
choice and that we were in effect
editing material for adult viewing which
was widely available in an unedited form
for a child
meta is due to return next week to
answer more questions as the inquest
into Molly Russell's death continues
Sadia Chaudhary Sky News in North London